[Music]
foreign
to Tech news briefing it's Wednesday
June 14th I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal
for years leading up to and through the
pandemic money was pouring into startups
but as economic conditions have changed
and interest rates have risen funding is
harder to come by and many
venture-backed startups are running out
of cash that's forcing leaders of these
startups to change their business plans
one of them is Samantha Edis CEO of the
fintech Park Place payments it is
founded the company in 2018 and it
raised four million dollars from Venture
investors but Edis told me she started
to notice a shift in the market last
year in 2022 towards the I would say end
of summer there were Rumblings of like
uh oh things are are changing fast you
sort of started hearing Rumblings of
like money's drying up the VCS are
tightening their belts everyone is
getting a lot more concerned about
what's to come and I started feeling
that too as a Founder what exactly did
you experience was at the end of 2022
you know what were your investors
telling you what were you hearing from
banks in terms of getting new money to
move the company forward yeah I mean
towards the end of summer we had a term
sheet from a lead investor and they just
were suddenly unable to fulfill the
amount that they had committed they just
suddenly were like it's not happening
and I'd already raised money around that
and that was a huge blow to us and it
put us in a pretty precarious situation
and so we had to Pivot and adjust really
fast so
sold the company six weeks ago was that
ever an expectation yours that you would
you would have to sell the company no
this was not the outcome I expected it
was
um very much you know I was building a
company that we were going to have for
years on end that was creating this
Revenue stream for tons of people
Freelancers that worked for us that was
the goal it was never the goal to sell
this early and it was really some of my
a couple of seasoned investors who came
to me and they were like this is the
time to sell the market is getting way
worse people are scrambling to find
outcomes you want to get ahead of this
of course not all startups are able to
find a buyer or make changes to stay
afloat it's a dire time in startup land
Yulia chernova covers venture capital
for wsj pro and she's been looking into
this broader downturn Yulia a lot of
funding for startups comes from Venture
Capital investors how has VC's approach
to investing in these young companies
changed oh so much change
um you know just VCS who fund these
companies have totally different
expectations from the expectations they
had a couple years ago so for the
founders what they have to demonstrate
the traction they have to show to
investors to get any kind of funding is
very different they VCS want to see much
more traction Revenue customers than
they did before for the same level of
investment and they want the companies
to grow fast but at the same time
something that they did didn't care
about as much before they want the
founders to keep costs low to keep head
count low to keep spending low right so
and to make every customer profitable so
this is very difficult for these high
growth companies and very few of them
can really persuade investors to give
them more money we heard from one
founder who talked about having to sell
her company in order to survive can you
tell us about some of the other tough
decisions that Founders are having to
make sure I mean sometimes companies
just run out of money they have no
choice but to shut down and try to sell
the assets piece by piece and then and
in some companies do manage to find a
way out by pivoting their business they
can no longer pursue the idea they
originally had but then maybe there is a
related idea that does work what about
the companies that can survive it seems
like we're seeing an uptick in that as
well how does that compare to past years
because startups generally you know shut
down all the time it's a hard business
yes you're right in the Venture Capital
space a lot of companies are not
expected to make it and uh when VCS
invest you know they invest in these
high risk high growth businesses with
the idea that only if you make it big
and then the rest of them don't so
what's going on now it does feel like
anecdotally from speaking with VCS from
speaking with Founders as well as these
companies that provide restructuring
services that there's much more shutting
down happening this year than last year
and then in 2021 and one of the reasons
is that there was just so much capital
in 21 both from VCS and from the
government that supported small
businesses that it seems like some of
the companies that maybe wouldn't have
survived without all that extra support
they're just now running out of money
what does all of this mean for the
Venture Capital firms to have all of
these shutdowns and and even all of
these pivots from some of the companies
they invest in well that's the big
question we are already seeing negative
returns for the first time for VC firms
overall that hit in the third quarter of
last year that was the most recent data
we have available and that was the first
time that there was kind of an annual
negative return for VC firms overall
since 2009 some of that is probably due
to shutdown some of that is just due to
lower evaluations for existing companies
that are still active but just are not
valued as highly so for the VCS the
existing portfolios are going to be
suffering and the values will be
suffering for sure at the same time for
the VCS the current market you know in
terms of new Investments looks pretty
good VCS like it when valuations are
down and when founders don't have a lot
of capital sources right so that VCS can
keep prices low and can buy into good
companies cheaper and VC's hope is that
they can now invest in these lean mean
money making machines you know which is
very different from 21 when every
company was like burning money and super
bloated what does this mean then from
the founders perspective for people who
want to start companies definitely much
harder to start the company now in terms
of raising money you have to show much
more to your investors prove that this
business will turn profitable or at
least on the kind of unit economics
level will turn profitable quickly and
that you can do it on the cheap sort of
you can grow fast on the cheap but there
are some advantages to the current
market for starting a company in terms
of access to talent and new employees
the fact that there were so many layoffs
in the tech Market means that startups
can also find new employees cheaper and
start building
all right that's wsj Pro Venture Capital
reporter Yulia chernova and that's it
for today's Tech news briefing for more
Tech stories head over to our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]